Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Luis Pescetti
El humor y el alivio de ser quienes somos
Hola.
Buenos días.
Como dijo Adrián yo, entre otras cosas,
hago humor sobre infancia y convivencia en familia.
No es exactamente sólo sobre niños.
Y convivencia en familia, eso incluye a los padres.
Entonces, por ejemplo, una vez escuché a una mamá que decía:
¡Mi hijo me tiene harta!
Entonces yo digo, bueno, voy a tomar eso y lo desarrollo.
Al finalizar el horario de clase llega una mamá a buscar a su hijo a la escuela
y la maestra le dice: "Señora, hoy Fernando se portó fatal.
--¿Otra vez?
--Pero fatal, fatal. No hace caso, contesta, se burla de los compañeros…
--Ah, pues entonces, deme otro
--Cómo que otro, ¿otro niño?
--Sí, porque yo tampoco sé que hacer.
--Pero es que no puede ser
--Ah, con su padre ya le dijimos. Pero si el no quiere hacer caso…
--Es que no se trata de eso, la escuela está llena de niños
--¡Pues cámbiemelo y listo!
--No, pero…
--Casi mejor pruebo con una niña, estoy pensando…
--Es que se me desordena todo, señora, luego vendrá la madre de la niña
--Sí, ya sé, pero yo vine primero"
Bueno, y el texto sigue, sigue, sigue y sigue, ¿no?
Cuando yo trabajo con niños, cuando trabajo haciendo humor
así cuento ya con que los niños son espectadores muy entrenados.
Lo primero que pudieron hacer fue sólo estar observando.
Y con las familias tienen montones de experiencias y de vivencias
en sus familias que son con las que yo aludo y me refiero.
Entonces oigo que una mamá, una amiga, me dice:
"Ricardito no me come nada".
♫ Ricardito no me come nada ♫
♫ Este niño se alimenta con el aire ♫
♫ Y eso que yo… ♫
Y eso si quieren lo podemos aprender y el que quiere y tiene ganas lo canta conmigo
♫ Ricardito no me… ♫
Por favor…
♫ Ricardito… ♫
El que quiere, si…
♫ Ricardito no me come nada ♫
♫ Este niño se alimenta con el aire ♫
♫ Y eso que yo lo llevo al médico ♫
♫ Y eso que yo le doy vitaminas ♫
♫ Y le preparo un sano guiso de hígado y cebolla ♫
♫ Ricardito no me come nada ♫
♫ Este niño se alimenta con el aire ♫
♫ Y eso que yo le preparo sopa ♫
♫ Y eso que yo le doy lechuga hervida ♫
♫ Y eso que yo le cocino brócoli con berenjenas ♫
♫ Ricardito no me come nada… ♫
Y sigue el texto, ¿no?
Entonces, o por ejemplo oigo, porque siempre
me nutro de las experiencias de las familias,¿no?
Oigo de las conversaciones y de la lucha de los padres, especialmente las mamás,
en hablar con sus hijos y que le cuenten como fue el día.
"¿Qué te pasó hoy, mi amor?"
Entonces les voy a pedir amablemente que Uds. una vez canten
la palabra "bien" y la otra vez canten la palabra "nada".
Sólo eso.
Yo voy a hacer de la madre.
♫ Hola mi amor, contame tu día ♫
--Bien
♫ Decime qué hiciste, ¿qué hubo de especial? ♫
--Nada
♫ ¿Cómo te fue en matemáticas? ♫
--Bien
♫ Atendiste el teléfono, ¿alguna novedad? ♫
--Nada
♫ Apagá la tele y decime en qué andás ♫
--Bien
♫ ¿Qué arreglaste con los chicos para el fin de semana? ♫
--Nada
♫ ¿Qué les pareció el trabajo que llevaste? ♫
--Bien
♫ ¿Qué hicieron en tu cuarto encerrados por tres horas? ♫
--Nada
Y sigue la canción.
Entonces, yo me di cuenta que tomaba las anécdotas que le pasaban,
que las devolvía exageradas como canción
y que lo que estaba haciendo era devolver una imagen de niño,
de la infancia y de la convivencia en familia que no responde al ideal, ¿no?
Y que cuando la gente oía eso pasaba, como ahora,
que se reía aliviada porque se reconocía en lo que les pasaba,
porque no eran los únicos, cuando nos equivocamos
es una de las pocas veces en que es un alivio no ser los únicos.
Y sobre las pasiones.
Y que eso genera un alivio cuando uno oye una historia así, ¿no?
Por ejemplo, había un espectáculo. Había un espectáculo…
de hecho, los chicos son espectadores tan entrenados,
que yo entraba a escena y sólo decía:
"¡No!"
Por supuesto, toda la sala inmediatamente decía…
"¡Sí!"
Exactamente.
Yo decía "¡No!"
-Sí
"¡No!"
-Bueno, sí, y me iba.
Entonces decían: No, no, no… no, no.
Y había otro espectáculo en el que yo entraba y en el más, de 0 a 100,
en el más completo y absoluto silencio empezaba a decir:
♫ Pasaremos a explicar ♫
♫ cómo se hacen los niños ♫
♫ una pregunta que ellos no siempre se atreven a formular ♫
♫ Porque nosotros no siempre nos atrevemos a contestar ♫
♫ Papá tie… ♫
La gente que había ido invitada por otros, que nunca había visto el espectáculo,
en ese momento sentía un vértigo. "¿Querés ir al baño, mi amor?"
♫ Papá tiene una semilla ♫
♫ que la guarda escondida ♫
♫ Porque no queda bien hablar con la semillita al aire ♫
♫ Mamá tiene un sobre ♫
♫ donde guarda un repollo ♫
♫ y ahora que digo repollo ♫
♫ Me acuerdo de los precios del mercado ♫
♫ El costo de la vida es un escándalo ♫
♫ Por eso niños mi mensaje es muy importante ♫
♫ Los adultos tienen muchas preocupaciones ♫
♫ Por eso hay que ayudarlos portándose bien ♫
Bueno, y sigue la canción.
¿Verdad que se parece a la explicación que nos dieron
sobre la última crisis financiera? ¿no?
Bueno, y ¿por qué hubo que ayudar a los bancos?
(Risas)
Bueno, entonces, ¿cómo ocurre?
O ¿cómo opera esto?
O ¿cómo lo hago?, ¿no?
Yo estoy atento, estoy atento a cosas que pasan
y estoy atento sobre todo a cuando algo salta especialmente,
valga la redundancia, a mi atención.
Una vez estaba en un semáforo, ejemplo,
y veo que pasa una mamá con dos hijos.
Uno pequeñito, con uno de esos triciclos diseñados para la foto
pero no para andar.
Son grandes y de plástico.
Y, entonces, él iba así peleando con su triciclo, cruzando la calle.
El hermano mayor adelante y este con el triciclo ahí
entre que lo disfrutaba y no podía avanzar bien.
La mamá se desesperó en mitad de la calle.
Le dijo: "Apurate, ¿querés?
Mirá lo que estás… y se demoró.
Y vi esto: que el mayor, que iba adelante, sin voltear,
expresó una sonrisa de satisfacción enorme.
Entonces yo pienso: "Si hago una canción que enseña a ayudar a cruzar la calle
no va a hacer reír. Si hago una canción que hable de ser un hermano mayor solidario,
lo único que voy a hacer es agregarle peso a su responsabilidad"
Entonces yo digo, bueno, voy a hacer una canción que haga reír,
y ¿qué hago?
Hago foco sobre su sonrisa de satisfacción,
cuando oyó el reto de la mamá a su hermano menor.
Entonces yo podría decir que la canción va por el lado:
♫ Hoy fue un día glorioso ♫
♫ Por fin mamá retó al intruso ♫
O, mejor, aumentar la emoción:
♫ Mamá empieza a mostrar ♫
♫ signos de cansancio ♫
O más todavía, voy más lejos:
♫ Supongo que hoy empezarán a hablar con papá ♫
♫ sobre cómo deshacerse de él ♫
♫ Siempre confié en que ellos me cuidarían ♫
O irónico:
♫ Hermano no sabes cuánto me dolió ♫
♫ cuando mamá se equivocó ♫
♫ y por algo que hiciste vos ♫
♫ me retó a mí ♫
♫ en vez de retarte a vos ♫
♫ por algo que hiciste vos ♫
Y así sé que eso va a hacer reír.
Entonces hice algo parecido con una canción:
♫ Me va a nacer un hermanito ♫
♫ qué contento que estoy ♫
♫ pum, pum, pum, pum ♫
Por favor esta parte, si Uds. quieren es, haciendo así la inclinación
♫ Me va a nacer un hermanito ♫
Lo están haciendo al revés…
(Risas)
♫ Me va a nacer un hermanito ♫
♫ ¡qué contento que estoy! ♫
♫ pum, pum ♫
♫ En casa hay un solo cuarto y a mí me daba miedo dormir solo ♫
♫ Y ahora mis papás me dijeron ♫
♫ Que no voy a tener más miedo ♫
♫ Porque viene un hermanito ♫
♫ A hacerme compañía ♫
♫ Y a usar mis juguetes ♫
♫ Me va a nacer… ♫
Y etc., etc. y sigue la canción.
Entonces les voy a dar otro ejemplo más de qué, de qué mirada encontré sobre…
sobre lo infantil y sobre esto de hacer reír y que tenía que ver…
obviamente cuando un chico llega al teatro,
llega como un espectador muy entrenado que es lo que dije,
pero además con una enorrrme carga de ya-sabe-de-lo-que-se-espera-de-él
y sabe de lo que se puede esperar de un adulto.
Y a los adultos nos pasa lo mismo.
Sabemos lo que se puede esperar de nosotros.
La expectativa es un gran aliado para mí.
Por ejemplo, estamos en una sala de operaciones.
Sentimos miedo.
No queremos estar ahí.
¿Qué mensaje nos va a ayudar?
Se acerca el anestesista y nos dice: "No deberías sentir miedo"
¡Ya sé que no debería sentir miedo!
Estoy sintiendo miedo porque no lo puedo controlar, precisamente.
O bueno, se acerca el anestesista y nos dice: "¡Ay, qué feo!
Miren el miedo que siente" No, un idiota.
O, se acerca el anestesista y nos dice: "¿Ves esta foto?
Es una foto de mis padres.
¿Sabes cuánto esfuerzo hicieron ellos para pagar mis estudios? ¿Y aún así sientes miedo?"
No, tampoco ayuda.
O, viene y nos dice: "Hola, soy tu amigo el anestesista"
¡Ahh, no quiero que seas mi amigo!
No, quiero que seas un buen anestesista.
"Te voy a explicar las drogas que vamos a usar hoy"
No, tampoco. Eso es una película de terror.
Entonces quiero mostrarles una carta que recibí de una niña.
Me llegan muchas cartas y dibujos.
Para Luis. Dice "Hola Luis, me llamo Agustina.
Tengo 6 años. ¿Sabes cómo te conocí?
En febrero del 2008 me operé en el hospital de niños Ricardo Gutiérrez
y fue ahí que el anestesista me cantó la canción de "El niño caníbal"
para que mis papás y yo nos riéramos un poco y no tengamos tanto miedo.
Nunca me voy a olvidar de eso y por eso siempre te recuerdo porque,
con vos, fue más fácil entrar a la sala de operaciones.
Te quiero mucho. Mis papis y hermanos, etc., etc."
Entonces...
(Aplausos)
...gracias
La canción del niño caníbal, de hecho, no es una canción que se enseñe
en la facultad de medicina a los anestesistas.
Es de un humorista cubano y dice:
♫ Yo soy un niño caníbal ♫
♫ y nadie me quiere a mí ♫
♫ no tengo amiguitos ♫
♫ porque ya me los comí ♫
Es de Virulo, un compositor cubano, ¿no?
Pero estuvo muy bien lo que hizo este tipo.
Hizo empatía, la trató como persona, confió que entendería los chistes
y le dio vitalidad al momento, que de eso se trata.
Y, al mostrarse como persona, se corrió él del lugar de poder.
Y yo cuando actúo, soy un adulto que me corro del lugar del poder también.
Conservo el lugar de autoridad, porque se trata de que tengo que llevar un show adelante,
pero me quito del lugar de poder.
Por ejemplo, hago una canción de terror.
A los chicos les encantan las canciones de terror.
Buuaaa jaa jaaa jaa jaa
♫ Era una noche ♫
Ay, perdón, perdón -digo.
Me parece que allá, un niño mostró un signo de miedo.
Y entonces en la sala empiezan a ver: "¿Quién mostró miedo?"
Porque cuando digo que voy a hacer una canción de terror dicen "¡Bien! ¡Bravo!"
"Mostró miedo un niño allá. Bien, voy a cambiar por otra"
Y empiezan, no, no, no, no.
"Sí, voy a cambiar por otra que cuenta la amistad
entre una tortuguita y un arbolito"
No, no, no.
Empieza a haber movimiento en la sala.
♫ Era una tortuguita amiga de un arbolito ♫
Y ahí empiezan No, no, por favor…
♫ y él no la visitaba porque estaba plantado ♫
Ahí ya los gritos son muchísimos.
Y empiezan a gritar.
Ustedes hoy son muy educados.
Y los gritos en la sala ahí ya son de que no me dejan seguir
y entonces yo digo: "Espérense, déjenme cantar"
Y empiezo a pelear con ellos.
Y ellos dicen: No, no, la de terror.
"No cállense. Esta es ecologista. Les va a gustar.
Además, les enseñaría a amar a la Naturaleza, a la cual pertenecen varios de Uds.,
déjenme que les diga"
A los chicos les encanta desesperar a un adulto.
Entonces ahí yo hago de adulto que pierde el control del show y se desespera.
Y ellos siguen gritando y yo digo:
"Al final hay muertos, hay sangre" Así como prometiéndoselos.
Y ellos dicen "No, no". Saben que es un engaño y que es una mentira.
Entonces después voy y canto la canción de terror.
Empecé a hacer eso, empecé a hacer eso:
"que ese momento soy muy fácil que se corra, que no haga esto, que haga lo otro",
porque de veras también me di cuenta que había niños en la sala, a veces,
que tenían miedo.
Y que yo tenía que tener en cuenta y cuidar eso.
Y que no tenía que avanzar sobre algo que podía dar miedo de verdad.
¿Entonces qué recurso empecé a utilizar?
Entonces empecé a decir, les voy a contar algo que a mí me daba miedo pero…
¡Ahhh!, el chico sentía un gran alivio porque se estaba depositando el miedo en mí,
que yo cuando era chico tenía miedo que hubiera
debajo de la cama sapitos de la noche.
Entonces, me avivé, y empecé a taparme con la sábana hasta acá.
Pero entonces tenía miedo que los sapitos de la noche
tuvieran un equipo de olfateadores y me saltaran a la cara.
Entonces, me avivé, y empecé a taparme…
A esa altura del show generalmente los chicos empiezan
a dar tips sobre qué es mejor… "con una bombilla para poder respirar por fuera"
Empiezan a compartir…
Yo digo, la imagen que más me guía a mí en el trabajo con niños
y en el humor en general, es decir que los niños son como inmigrantes.
De hecho, lo son. Son como inmigrantes en el tiempo.
Yo viví 12 años fuera de mi país.
Uds. saben que cuando uno está como inmigrante, se acerca a ese nuevo país,
llega a ese nuevo país, con una mezcla de necesidad pero también de resistencia.
Necesita ser eficaz, aprender todas las reglas de ese nuevo país, de ese nuevo mundo,
pero a la vez da mucha nostalgia haber dejado un mundo cálido,
conocido, más familiar.
Entonces, todo lo que hagamos como adultos habilitándoles eso…
yo no quiero ser el de migraciones.
Yo como adulto que trabaja con niños, no quiero.
Yo lo convoqué, yo lo llamé, yo quiero heredarte el mundo,
te lo quiero dar, yo me voy a correr, pero mientras tanto vamos a convivir.
Y mientras convivamos, nos vamos a tratar los dos como sujetos semejantes.
Yo sé algunas cosas y tengo que llevar este show adelante.
A veces pasa que los papás, como están un poco cansados de la tarea que dura 24 horas,
ya saben cómo es, abierto todo el año.
Entonces llegan al show y dicen: "¡ah, no, que se haga cargo!"
Y los chicos empiezan a correr, y entonces yo paro el show.
Cuando pasa una cosa así, paro el espectáculo.
No siempre se puede hacer humor.
El humor es como la bicicleta, yo digo.
No podés ir en bicicleta a todas partes, todo el tiempo, ni fuerte.
Hay que ir con cuidado. A veces se usa, a veces no.
Y a veces uno para.
Para el show y dice: "no, mi amor, mientras yo estoy acá arriba este espacio es mío"
Vuelve con los papás y sigue el show.
Entonces yo elijo dejar un lugar de poder donde mientras yo tenga el poder
te pongo una pata encima, pero un lugar de cuidado y de autoridad
en relación a lo que hago.
Y, para seguir juntos. En síntesis, lo que quería decirles, es que cada sociedad
tiene una imagen del niño, de la infancia, de lo que es ser papás,
de lo que es criar, de lo que es educar.
Si esa imagen se basa en un ideal es más difícil, mucho más pesado.
Si esa imagen se basa en algo real, en lo cotidiano,
en lo que nos pasa a nosotros,
nos vamos a sentir reconocidos y sentir gratitud y alivio.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)